all right guys
bang bang i've got brock here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
yeah my pleasure thanks for having me
for sure let's just jump right into your
background kind of tell us everything
you did before you got to lindeo
that's a great way to quite a ways to
start uh
so short and sweet um i i've been an
entrepreneur since college i was at byu
i was playing soccer there
i heard about an entrepreneurial
competition kind of like the tv show the
apprentice
uh without trump saying you're fired and
the glitz and glamour and all that but
we had
100 entrepreneurs that applied they
narrowed it down to 20
20 of us went through an eight-week boot
camp where we were learning about being
an entrepreneur and it was competition
we did all these things and at the end
um
they chose five and uh gave them each
fifty thousand dollars to start a
business
so i was one of the five uh that was
fortunate to win the fifty thousand
dollars and i could use that money to do
anything that i wanted as far as any
business i looked at buying a
an ice cream store and looked at
building a technology company and
and every business that i was talking to
the main challenge was that they all
needed financing they needed money
somehow to grow
or start their business and and um so
you know early on my career was we were
going to connect these entrepreneurs to
wealthy
private angel investors and we kind of
built this dating website
and and uh literally made every mistake
in the book along the way and
but realized something pretty valuable
along the way which is most businesses
in america
are main street businesses they're
restaurant owners and landscapers and
all that type of thing
and they don't need they're not going to
be the next uber and facebook and
and all these they're going to be
they're going to be good businesses but
they don't need a million dollars so we
changed the model on its head and
started focusing on debt financing and
and so that's uh and and and the way
we've we've gone with it uh with lending
connecting entrepreneurs to debt
financing and banks and
credit unions and fintech lenders across
the country since then so
that's the very shortened version
absolutely and i think what's so
interesting about your business is it's
lending and it's small businesses
uh for those that don't know uh or
haven't been paying attention there was
this public health crisis with a
pandemic
that then caused an entire economy in
the united states and then economies
around the world to shut down
the velocity of money goes down there's
massive massive issues
uh if you're a large corporation with
billions of dollars on your balance
sheet
you're not maybe you're not doing okay
right but uh but but
you can survive right you've got access
to capital you've got access to partners
you can raise equity quickly
um you can kind of do all the things you
need small businesses don't
have that and i think early on in march
and april i went back and i looked at
some data
and it was something like most small
businesses especially in the restaurant
and food industries
they only have about two weeks of cash
on hand in their bank account right so
they can't even make it 30 45 days
without
having uh you know kind of no revenue on
top of that they don't have access to
capital right they can't raise equity
very quickly especially when every
investor is actually
not deploying capital but actually
trying to find cash and hoard it during
uncertainty
and so you guys became this great option
maybe talk about like in the early days
of the pandemic
what you guys saw as the opportunity and
then we'll get into kind of how you guys
actually executed
but but what were you seeing in march
and into april uh during this
economic shutdown yeah so march it was
crazy time where all of a sudden you
know we everyone's starting to recognize
that pandemic's hitting and we're
shutting down the nba
and all the different sports teams and
and um
you know we started to recognize that
these businesses to no fault of their
own
are going to be in a really tough spot
um
and uh we started to see that
you know the the congress was going to
pass a package a stimulus package the
greatest stimulus pack or the
the largest stimulus package in the
history of the us to provide every
business owner in america access to
these
paycheck protection loans and when we
caught wind of that i
sent a text to it to our board members
and said
lendio is perfectly positioned to help
these small business owners
in fact the text was it was a quote
there's a winston churchill quote
uh and it was it says this to every man
there comes
in his lifetime that special moment when
he is figuratively
tapped on the shoulder and offered a
chance to do a very special thing
unique to him and fitted to his talents
what a tragedy
if that moment finds him unprepared or
unqualified for that which would be his
finest hour
and and i just you know we didn't know
what the ppp program was going to be
like
but we knew that millions of business
owners across the country
were debit were going to be devastated
they they were seeing their cash
you know go out the window they were
seeing that they were gonna have to do
layoffs and shut their doors and turn
off their lights and
and our mission at lendio is fueling the
american dream
and in that moment we decided to change
our mission temporarily to saving the
american dream
and we were going to go all in so the
text i sent to my board was
i don't know what this means i don't
know if we're going to make money i
don't know
what's going to happen but we're going
to go all
in and do everything we can to help as
many small business owners get access to
capital and we have the platform to be
able to make
a significant impact um and uh
so in a matter of a couple weeks we
did we stopped everything we were doing
from an operations perspective we have
300 or 350 employees
we dedicated our engineering team on
building a digital app
we went out and onboarded 250 financial
institutions and by the way
normally when you onboard a bank it
takes six to 12 months right if the
slowest moving
organizations in in the world and and uh
but we did it in 10 days we
onboarded 250 provided technology for
them to accept the ppp loan
we hired um we went out on a limb and
hired 250 employees
in 10 days all working from home
workstations that we had to
you know get and ship to their house and
train them
remotely and and we just said there are
businesses out there that we need to
help get to get access to capital and
the reason why
is because a lot of businesses their
bank that they worked with either was
not approved
for an sba loan or or not approved to
offer sba loans they weren't sba lenders
or their bank was prioritizing other
customers that were much larger than
them
and which meant there were all these
business owners that were at a
disadvantage and we felt like we could
make an impact and help them so
we started seeing their writing on the
wall and decided we're going for it
yeah what's so crazy is i remember
thinking back in you know really april
kind of once the
ppp program got approved and we started
to get some numbers around just how
quickly i think that first tranche went
it was literally gone in like less than
24 hours or less than 12 hours maybe
um and then also all the stories piled
in of like
oh the bank's best customers they got
all the loans first
like you kind of have this sense of just
like you want to stick your middle
finger up and say you know hey bankers
like
i knew you would do that but the fact
that you did it still pisses everybody
off
right yeah um and so you know thankfully
these businesses had options like lindeo
um to kind of get to it when i saw the
numbers from what you guys have done so
far so
uh i think these are correct but correct
me if i'm wrong uh over a hundred
thousand small businesses you guys have
helped kind of access that
uh some form of capital most of it being
pvp loans
uh and over eight billion dollars of
funds that they were able to tap
into which is just when you think of
those numbers like you can rattle off
millions and billions and thousands and
all this kind of stuff but like
a hundred thousand small businesses is
an absolute operational nightmare i've
got to imagine
uh it's a technological nightmare in
terms of i can only imagine like the
surges
um that you guys were getting especially
when everyone's so uh kind of fearful
uh the program had a lot of uh you know
unknowns to it i think a lot of banks
were kind of slow because they didn't
fully understand everything
um talk a little bit just about like
now looking back over the last seven
eight months like how does it
feel to have you know over a hundred
thousand businesses eight billion
dollars in uh funding access
and know that like you and your team
were able to kind of facilitate that
well during the moment i mean it was uh
it was way more customers than we
we've ever seen before in fact there was
one day i was on cnn and cnbc right at
beginning
um both uh stations uh the first day
talking about what was happening and we
saw a thousand times more traffic in
that afternoon
than we had seen on any other day
previous to that day
um it was just nuts and and not a
thousand percent
a thousand times 1000 x yes and
fortunately our engineering team is
amazing and everything kind of
piece still still stood together and and
and held
we didn't crash um and
you know during in the moment you're
going through this and you're like
i'm not sure if this is going to be the
best thing we ever did or the worst
thing we ever did
because you're trying every business
owner has a story
and and you're trying to help every
single one of them
and many of them it became personal
because it's it's
you know it's my brother and my
brother-in-law that are like texting me
every day am i going to be able to get a
loan and
every person that you've ever met in
your life that that has owned a business
that knows you what you do it whether
that's from elementary school
or college or the community or your best
friend's neighbor
or whoever is reaching out to you
with this urgent call that
my business is gonna go out of business
and i can't make payroll
if i don't get a loan please help me
and so you can imagine the amount of
stress and pressure that you
feel um as as you're getting that all
day long from
everyone uh and it's not like you know
that happens once a month it's like 10
times a day
uh so you know at the time we were just
like feeling this immense amount of
pressure it was neglecting
you know my family and and it was waking
up
early you know 4 35 and literally going
to bed at midnight and
all day long without any time to shower
or eat and i'm not
i'm not even exaggerating these things
sometimes you you say that and it sounds
great but
literally it was just like this pressure
every moment
to help these small business owners um
and um there were times where i thought
it was gonna crash and burn like we
we didn't have like let's tell you this
real short story
you mentioned this first weekend how the
money was going so fast and and all
these business owners seeing the capital
like i need to get in on this if i don't
i don't know if there's gonna be another
chance
and and we had 300 banks right from the
get-go that all said i can take as many
customers you can send us
but what they didn't none of us
anticipated was in that first weekend
they would get
more loan volume applications in that
weekend than they had ever seen
in in and they said they'd been mourned
that weekend and they've seen the last
15 years combined
um and so all of a sudden these banks
came back to us on monday saying we went
from 300 to literally zero overnight
because the bank said we can't take on
any customers
we've got more than enough for our own
with our own customers
sorry and we had at that time already
had you know
tens of thousands of business owners
that had signed up to lend you
applying and so there was this moment
from monday
to about wednesday where we were
scrambling saying who who which lenders
can we send these customers to
and uh we ended up cutting a deal uh 11
p.m
on wednesday night with a lender that
ended up taking on 25
000 customers and two and a half billion
dollars of loans and like
there were moments like that all along
the way
where you just again you didn't know if
this was the best thing that ever
happened to you or the worst thing that
ever happened to you
um but in the end
looking back and saying 120 000
businesses
8 billion and each of those has a story
1.2 million jobs
looking back at that impact we have and
and
seeing the videos of thank you
car or the thank you videos and the
testimonials and the emails and all the
things that
we did and and sometimes i'll go and
i'll meet someone and they'll be like i
got a loan from you
you know during this time and um
it's incredible it's ten times more
challenging than anything i've ever done
but ten times more rewarding
what was it like negotiating the deal at
like literally the 11th hour
uh and you're like hey i got a lot of
people who need money
and they're all counting on me to get
this deal done well
it wasn't public of the time and i don't
know if i should make it public now but
but um as an agent
in the in the thing your margins are
tiny okay you can get
one percent a half a percent or a
quarter of a percent
and um and and i said you know what
and and we could barely make any money
on that or to even
make it happen but the cause was worth
it
um but i cut a deal that night 11 p.m
the night where we were going to give up
50
of our economics um and for the first 10
000 loans that we funded we
would give up 50 of our economics and
and
um and that was painful we didn't make
any money on any of those loans but i
didn't care
i want we were motivated to help those
small businesses
and so when we got that deal cut it was
like
an amazing you know it was it was
awesome um just because it opened up the
opportunity to help
these small business owners then we
ended up going and adding a bunch of
other lenders that could
take on more customers and so on but
that first deal
we cut was uh was critical absolutely
and obviously one of the big questions
has always been around the ppp program
just like okay cool in march april into
uh may and june like we got money into
the hands of these small businesses
how long can it last right and so maybe
give us an update as to like
what you guys are seeing on the small
business front today some
states have or cities have business
still
shut down some have them kind of
partially open some are back to
normal from like uh you can open and do
whatever you want just what are you
seeing
in terms of the financial needs of these
small businesses today
yeah so there's three things i would say
briefly one number one is there's a lot
of small businesses that went through
that pills ppp loans in the two and a
half months and that's all it was
supposed to last
it was to cover your payroll for two and
a half months and they've burned through
that and they're in a tough spot
a lot of restaurants and retail and
hotels and theaters and all of those
and to no fault of their own especially
in some of those places where the
restrictions of the pandemic are so
tight
um and i and i can't tell you how
extremely frustrated i am personally and
the
and and the our small businesses should
be
at our politicians right now the fact
that they have gone this long
you know bickering over a stimulus
package that they're trying to you know
with their own personal agendas and and
they're playing politics and meanwhile
you know businesses are shutting their
doors permanently
um hundreds of i mean we have nearly
you know i've seen stats of a couple
hundred thousand sixty percent of them
are shut down
permanently and and yet we can't
everyone agrees on ppp
but there's other things they're trying
to insert in the package that they don't
agree on so ppp is being held hostage at
least the second round
that's frustrating i i um and and we're
pushing as hard as we can
to try and get our politicians to do
something
the second thing i would say is that
other lenders have you know they stopped
lending in april but then
they've recognized so that yeah the the
rug was pulled out from under them april
1st
but since then there's been some it's
totally different than pre-covered but
at least it's stable
and it's a different stable but at least
it's stable so lenders are now starting
to be able to underwrite
again because they can look at the last
three to six months of cash flow and and
recognize okay this business this is you
know it's maybe revenues are down 25
percent police is
consistently down 25 and i can
underwrite to that
um so you know literally week over week
month over month
our volume at lendio the loans that
we're doing and
they're getting funded by our lenders is
is increasing
because lenders are starting to get more
aggressive and
comfortable around around lending again
and then there's this third set of small
businesses that
you know the pandemic's the best thing
that's ever happened to them
from you know recreational vehicles
whether it's rvs or
mountain bikes or boats or uh
you know or uh you know i hear
construction um home remodels
you know a lot of those things people
are at home and they're seeing
their home needs to be repaired or
upgraded or things like that so those
things i i think there's some industries
that are doing extremely well
um so those are some of the things that
we're seeing in the market
absolutely and what's crazy to me is in
a span of
a couple of weeks you hired 200 to 250
new employees what is that like like to
me that's such a
a crazy thing and it sounds like maybe
it was almost doubling the size of the
business right
from a headcount standpoint so talk
through that um kind of experience
yeah so i never thought we would go
through an experience like that i mean
um you know scaling is one thing and you
know we were at a pace of hiring you
know something like 20 a month which was
a big deal
but 250 over 10 days um and what made it
even more challenging is that we were
all work from home
so getting the the the computers into
their hands
getting training um and
so there's we we were extremely creative
on how we did that we had some
other offices in the area that were
looking to do
furloughs and and so it was kind of like
we were renting some of their team
members for a period of time
we had people that were you know all of
a sudden universities were closed and
everything was online so they needed a
summer job
uh we were hiring our team members you
know
uh their spouse or their brother or
their their son
or whoever you know a lot of uh personal
referrals
um and but one thing that became really
clear so
that the logistically it was it was
quite the challenge
but one thing i it became so clear to me
was that
people love to be a part of a cause they
want to be
they want to go and help they want to
solve the problem they want to do
something bigger than themselves and
and we had so many that just bought
completely into this idea of saving the
american dream and helping small
businesses and that what was
that's what was incredible is they
sacrificed a lot and their training
it wasn't a 95 job it was like i need to
know this because i need to be i want to
be able to be a part of this i want to
i wanna help more businesses and so i
need to become an expert
and uh so it was a lot of logistics but
a lot of like clear motivation of these
team to
be a part of something special yeah and
in terms of
where you guys are now so you have this
massive influx of
kind of small businesses and activity
for the ppp program
how do you think that kind of positions
you guys moving forward is this
something where
you'll kind of continue to help these
small businesses and there'll be some
ongoing support
is it something where you're kind of
dependent on what the government
programs are
just talk through kind of how you see
the relationship with those 120 000
uh small businesses moving forward yeah
so ppv for us is just another loan
product so we're a marketplace and we've
got a lot of loan products and some come
and go and so right now
you know it's ppp is one of the products
that we offer but we offer
other sba loans lines of credit term
loans and so on
so those businesses that we helped uh
get a ppp loan there's other
things that we're trying that we want to
help them with number one is
we have a cash flow product it's kind of
like a quickbooks lite where it
pulls our bank data each day and it
gives them cash alerts so it cashes up
and cashes down
all invoicing management bookkeeping
things like that to help them
you know preserve and manage cash so
that's one thing that
we've got a lot of those customers that
are that are finding benefit
in that product the second thing is is
that
you know with those customers we are
going back to them and making sure they
are aware of other loan products that
are available
in case they need another loan for
growth or or other reasons
down the road to be able to help them
secure other types of financing
um and and so you know it's really it's
we make money through our lenders we're
trying to do everything we can to add
value to those business owners
to to build
a relationship of trust that when they
need financing they go to lendio
absolutely and um do you see a world
where eventually you'll
help on the equity side as well or is it
pretty much
uh debt is really kind of the sweet spot
and you see that as like
the number one best way to help the
small business
so because we started with equity
financing
um and uh i have i have
nightmares i even start twitching a
little bit when i think about getting
back in
equity and there's reasons for that but
the couple reasons why
number number one is um
with equity capital there's no formula
um in other words if
if you're investing in a business you
what the types of business you're going
to invest in will depend on how you feel
that day whether you connected with that
entrepreneur
how your 401k is doing and
it's so it's so subjective right and and
there's no way to build
you know uh a plus b equals c and you
can do that every single time
um and and the second thing is is that
business owners
like raising capital is it's just it's a
relationship thing
it's a challenge it is who you know
um and uh and and and then third
only about one percent of businesses
actually raise venture capital or angel
capital and
and you know i'd prefer to focus on the
99 of main street america that needs
you know debt financing so for a bunch
of those reasons
uh we'll probably allow someone else to
to go and solve that problem
absolutely and then in terms of kind of
future plans for lendio itself
um you'll kind of continue to uh service
these small businesses with various
um types of debt products talk a little
bit just about
how does this affect or position you
guys from a head count standpoint moving
forward how do you think about
kind of growing the business it's become
quite popular for
uh you know versions of fintech
companies to want to go public or
uh you know kind of do all kinds of
things that maybe over the last 10 years
hasn't been as popular how do you kind
of just view
building the business so not necessarily
serving the customers but like you have
to build a business that you're
responsible for employees
how do you see that uh evolving over
time
yeah i mean it all starts with uh you
know building a marketplace that's the
best most efficient
uh way to get loans uh for business
owners and then there's a bunch of
things that we can do to build office so
if you start with that foundation which
is a very difficult foundation to build
and start and
marketplaces are challenging you know
themselves but we think about then
okay we've got two customer bases on one
side we've got financial institutions on
the other side we have
small businesses how do we build a
relationship with them that will last a
long time so on the small business side
i talked about our sunrise product is
helping them with cash flow and helping
them with bookkeeping and invoicing and
and we have a really high
you know retention rate there and
some exciting and and what i love about
that is that we turn it into a one-time
loan application to what i call an
always-on application
meaning we can alert you
the minute that you're qualified for a
loan down the road
um and you're just running your business
we're helping you run your cash and all
of a sudden we say
hey you're you're getting alert on your
phone you're qualified for a fifty
thousand dollar loan
click here to take it um because we
already had access to that cash flow
data
and add more value that way on the flip
side of the business it's
with with our lenders we've never seen
it in in
history in uh in the history of
financial institutions
a more urgent demand to go digital most
of these banks
they realize no one wants to go into the
branch anymore and fill out a piece of
paper and an application they all want
to apply
online and they want to do it through
technology and things like that so
a lot of the technology we built has uh
we can we can go to our lender base as
well and and
deliver technology that way so and
there's a lot of other
pieces to it my point is is we feel like
it's enormous market it's very
inefficient there's a
as a very large opportunity we're
growing 75
you know to 100 year over year
so um if we keep that up then that'll
create optionality for us to be able to
decide
know where we take the business
absolutely uh where can people go to
find more about lindeo or find you on
the internet
yeah so um lendo.com it's free for small
business owners we make our money
through
lenders um and then on twitter uh
brock blake is where you can find me
awesome
i wrap up every episode asking the same
two questions
and then you'll get to ask me one to
finish up uh the first question is what
is the most important book that you've
ever read
wow a business book or any book
whatever whatever you want yeah
all right um i'll i'll probably take
i'm going to take a a personal a book
that means
is near and dear to my heart uh and it's
changed my life
um is the book of mormon um
and so i'm gonna take that one um
because it it helps it
has there's been nothing that as i've
studied
um i'm a religious person and i've
studied a lot of different things and
and there's been
and what i love about that book is that
it um there's there's promises
to it uh well it gives you guidance on
why we're here and where we're going
that whole adage of where we came from
why we're here where we're going
um and it and studying it each day gives
me a lot of peace in my life um
and so that that book uh
would would be my would be my selection
so one of the things that i've noticed
is uh the books that people think were
the most important in their life have a
lot to do with when they read it do you
remember the first time how old you were
or kind of where you were in your life
when you read it yeah
it was um you know i i learned heard
about it or other things like that but
where it really
came to life for me when was my freshman
year at college
yeah it um it's crazy to me uh
right into like 16 to 25.
there's a lot of people who that seems
to be the age when they read something
and it could be a religious text it
could be fiction non-fiction
you know philosophical whatever it is
but it just it resonates and
uh and some of it's probably uh
nostalgia in some cases some of it is
they took a specific learning uh and
some of it is you know like the
religious text where they continue to
read it on a daily basis
and it's kind of stuck with them their
life so it's uh it's cool to hear that
story
you're looking for answers right you're
trying to figure out what's
what does all this stuff mean why are we
here you know well
so i had somebody come on the podcast
once and uh he very
intelligently said that every human will
ask the same two questions in their life
one is what happens when we die and the
second is
are we here alone and so my second
question's more fun which is
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
[Laughter]
uh i believe that there is life on other
on other planets i don't know if
it's the form of aliens um or or if
there are other earths out there or
other things like that but i
i do believe there are other spheres
that the there are
there's life signs of life absolutely i
don't know if there's green
green martians but
yeah the green men i don't know if i'm
sold on but uh but intelligent life i
think that uh it's just too big it's
gotta be there somewhere right
yep i agree amen uh you could ask me one
question to finish up what do you got
for me
so um for you like what was your
favorite interview that
that you've done um or whether that's
been
on a podcast or just like an experience
where you've sat down with someone and
you were just like this was incredible
um yeah who was it and what was the
topic
so people are gonna like revolt when i
say this it's nobody i've ever talked to
the podcast
uh the the podcast is um
it's great and i meet amazing people and
i get to hear some really amazing
stories but i do think that there's this
sense of
uh um some people are very guarded
and they don't want to be vulnerable
because they know a lot of people are
going to listen to it and things like
that
and uh in person it used to be a little
bit better remote is even harder right
because then it's like
uh kind of you're talking into the
portal that is your uh your computer or
whatever
uh but the best conversations i've ever
had are with complete strangers
like you know i can think of a couple
off the top of my head
uh you know when i was in iraq i met a
kid who barely spoke english and just
like seeing that viewpoint
or um i was with my wife in bulgaria
where she's from and just met somebody
who spoke
you know english and just kind of again
getting their viewpoint or
being on a train in italy and some guy
happens to sit down next to us who
is a restaurateur in uh in the united
states and he starts talking about kind
of his life
and those are the stories i think that
are like really really interesting
um some of it's probably a fascination
with like people who have a story
different than your own
right and then also two is like everyone
always focuses on
the most successful people the richest
people the people who
kind of accomplished uh more than
everyone else and it's just like
aspirational tell me how you did
it or you know kind of tell me your
story uh but i tend to think that many
of the people with the most interesting
stories are the people who
maybe aren't the most successful right
they're the people who are kind of still
in the story
um and so i i don't know if i could pick
one but it's
those types of situations uh to me are
like
incredibly rewarding which uh almost
seems like um
you know it's counter-intuitive or
blasphemous for somebody who spends so
much time talking to people on a podcast
uh to say but for sure that would be the
answer totally get it
can i ask one more of course come on one
more
so what uh you know each of us go
through these times where we're
we're thinking something there's a topic
there's a cause there's something that
is consumes our thoughts that we're
passionate about that
you know in our com when we when we when
we aren't forced to talk about something
else we choose to talk about this topic
what is that for you right now yeah i
think it's
probably something around like financial
education right and and i say that
mainly because
um to me it's just the one thing that
uh we can give to lots and lots of
people
it's not controversial at all and it
probably can have
um a significant if not the biggest
impact on someone's life
right and it's just this idea of i think
a lot about um kind of education and
knowledge is
the uh equalizer right so you
if you look at something as simple as
just uh hey
yes you should save money to a point and
then you should
invest the rest right and so like have
your rainy day fund but investing is how
you will not only protect yourself
uh from all sorts of things around
inflation et cetera but also like that's
how you're gonna grow your wealth and
rather than trading your hours for money
and you know all these kind of like
very basic timeless financial education
um you know kind of learnings or lessons
uh
they're timeless for a reason but what
you start to realize
is there's probably 50 percent maybe
more of the country
if you went and you sat down with them
like they don't know this stuff right
and
it literally is just a lack of knowledge
and then you explain it to them
and they see the world differently right
and so you know again most people who
come on the podcast have been fortunate
enough where like somebody along the way
taught them that right whether it was
literally they just happened to stumble
upon an article on the internet or a
parent or
a friend or whatever but i think that's
the one thing of like
if we could get everyone to understand
kind of the basics
one you probably have a lot fewer
problems in society just around like
people wouldn't go and get into you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars of debt
and kind of all this like crazy stuff
that
creates these chain reactions but then
also too like you literally can improve
the quality of somebody's life that
doesn't mean somebody's gonna go from
you know hey i make minimum wage to now
i'm going to be a multi-millionaire
but it does mean that can you help that
person over a 20-year period have enough
money so that they can actually retire
when retirement comes right and like i
think a lot of people get
lost in this like oh my god you don't
have a mansion that must mean you didn't
do well in life
like right no actually for the majority
of people like retiring on time
is a like a bar of like i did the right
things
right and if you can do it earlier than
that even better
um and so i just think that like that's
the stuff to me that uh
it's so simple that people kind of like
forget about it because they want to you
know
have us live forever or go find aliens
or like you know like all that stuff's
fun i love talking about it
but but like the basic stuff is still
the basic stuff and
so i think there's a big impact there
what is it
oh man
well that that that there's some there's
some depth to that
uh your your response um
and i i agree with i agree with that
comment
um you know i right now with the
election and everything
that's going on you know i one of the
conversations that i'm having it's just
um i feel like back in the day um
as a society we we all that we pretty
much want
in the end a similar result and
whether we were red or blue or whatever
whatever stigma or label we put on
ourselves
we would we would look at someone across
the way and say
okay i don't agree exactly with
their opinion on how to get there but i
believe
in that they want the same this very
similar result in the end that i do
and so i'm going to respect their
approach um
and and and i i just um
you know for me it's just disappointing
a lot of my thought right now just
because the election is is so
is disappointing with how um
divisive the the nation is around you
know any topic any it doesn't matter
what it is we have to you know we have
to fight over it and i just
would love to be able to see you know um
us respect that's what makes this nation
great is this
united states of america and and we we
all have different opinions and we all
value those opinions but we can respect
each other's opinions
it's not always a fight so anyways a lot
of my thought right now is just around
how do you
and i think a lot of this comes from
leadership you know how do you
unite people versus create contention
and division and
um and um
i i feel like it's a tough time with the
pandemic and
and everything that's happened from you
know from the
from um from race and and social
injustice and some of those things that
our nation could use a lot of you know
healing
uh through and and i'm anxious for that
to happen so that's a lot of my thoughts
right now around how do you how do you
how do you solve for that i went through
an exercise with a friend uh probably
two three weeks ago i said to him you
give me a topic and i'm going to tell
you both sides of the debate
and not because i'm some expert on this
stuff yeah but just to show you there is
two sides
in terms of and it usually falls on the
party lines of republicans and democrats
but
in general there's kind of a you know
very divisive extreme
type view in these situations and he's
like why do you what's your point and i
was like
because the topic you could throw out
could be super mundane like masks
right right and there's like crazy
extreme views
and by the way that's not uh a pro or
a con like in terms of the argument
right like both of the extreme sides of
that argument
are pretty crazy and so it's like i i
just think that uh when you get in a
world where whether it's
mass whether it's the federal reserve
small businesses
you know i literally said to him i said
you could say american dream
and i could show you two different sides
of that right which is like
pretty pretty crazy and i i do think
that um
i'm assuming that you're uh about the
same age as i am i'm in my
early to mid 30s and you know when you
kind of look at it it's like
there's going to be a generation where
they eventually kind of come back around
right and i think that there was you
know probably our grandparents were
uh relatively moderate not super
divisive
very kind of leadership oriented et
cetera you get some
diversion from that and i think that you
kind of then go back into more of a
consolidation
where people say hey look like you want
more moderate
um kind of candidates that embrace you
know
unity and all this kind of stuff and go
through a cycle of that and then you get
back to the divisiveness and so like
i try to remind myself like we still
live in the
best safest most prosperous time in
human history
but if you like that if you like you
know if you watch television or anything
like that but uh
that's my one saving grace is uh it it
might not feel great but uh but it's
better than it ever was before which is
uh it's crazy to think about but uh
but amen there's uh it's not all bad
it's not all divisive it's not all
you know negative there's some amazing
positive things that are happening and
we're fortunate to be here and so i
don't want it to come across
ungrateful i'm just it's more of how do
we solve some of these problems that
exist
and create more unity listen
you guys are doing a fantastic job
there's a lot of small businesses who
are very big fans of
what you guys have done over the last
six or seven months so i think you're
doing just fine
thanks paul appreciate it all right
brock listen thank you so much for doing
this we're going to
have to do this again in the future yeah
i've really enjoyed it thanks for having
me on thanks for all you do you're doing
some incredible work and love listening
to you